DAN GALPIN: So I
wanted to begin.
My job is basically to be awake
this early in the morning.
I'm usually very funny when
I haven't had much sleep.
And this is always an
exciting week, the week of IO.
So I actually wrote
my name in the notes,
just so I'd remember
to say them.
Because this is
usually a time when
we're just running around,
trying to get everything
ready for tomorrow.
And this is always a
really fun thing to do,
to meet with you guys today.
And so I'm really excited
that Bill asked me to be here.
I've been doing this
for a really long time.
I've been working to make
Android development better,
delivering some modestly
memorable presentations,
and occasionally, maybe more
memorable looks over the years.
I particularly like
the Jean Valjean look
I have on the left, over there.
So the first thing I like to
do is summarize all the things
that I thought were cool
about the day we had at GDC.
And so how many people,
by a show of hands,
actually attended and saw
all of our GDC sessions?
All right.
Well, that's usually
about what I expected.
That's why I do this.
And I grouped these to
kind of help myself.
So we talked about
a lot of things
about what Google Play is doing.
So I'll put my
Google Play hat on.
We mentioned that in
the last 12 months,
the number of Android users
who installed a game more than
doubled, compared to
the previous year,
and 40% of that growth is
coming from these emerging
markets, such as Brazil,
India, Indonesia, and Mexico.
We recognize that because
about half of mobile gamers
are women we kicked off
an initiative to celebrate
and empower women as
players and creators.
We did a lot of stuff
inside the store
to actually improve the
way that people find games.
We improved search on
play with personalization,
such as the search
refinements you
see on the left and
recommendations on the right.
Nice!
That is because I'm
running a dev version.
I swear, hilarious.
This is what happens
when you have to run
the unstable version of Chrome.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
I have no idea what's
going to happen there.
That was pretty cool.
This is why live
presentations are really fun.
I am going to try
to kill everything
that's not important.
And I'm hoping that
won't happen again.
But, if it does,
we'll roll with it.
All right, let's go back.
I thought this would be so cool!
I did this last year
on my Chromebook
running the latest version,
but this is just, uh--
all right.
Let me pull that off
and start over again.
Where was I?
I was talking about something
about Google Play, I remember.
AUDIENCE: You said
better search.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, better search.
We had-- let me try
this one more time.
That's amazing.
Thank you all for
putting up with me.
And this-- real fun.
Maybe next time I'll actually--
oh, no!
Now it's all-- this
is turned back on?
All right, that's OK.
AUDIENCE: You want
to switch to this?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
maybe I should--
Joe, why don't you put
it up on the laptop.
We'll switch over once I--
give me two seconds here.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, sure.
DAN GALPIN: OK.
We might do a switch in between.
If it crashes again, then I'm
going to switch over to that.
This does not happen on the
release versions, by the way.
Trust me.
Our software's perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Will it
happen on my machine?
DAN GALPIN: Well,
the nice thing is
I could move to another
machine really quickly.
This is why I should
have redundant machines,
clearly, when I'm doing this.
All right, let's go back.
All right, blah blah blah,
lots of animations about IO
that are probably making it
run out of memory, hands,
play updates.
We're going with
lots of expansion.
We're doing some cool stuff with
search, personalized search.
One of the things
we've done is we've
actually elevated games
as its own destination,
in Google Play.
And that's really
important because it's
a foundation for creating
a lot of experiences
in the story that
are unique to games--
such as more immersive
recommendations,
like showing trailers or
screenshots of actual gameplay.
And we also want to give users
a lot more control on how
they explore the catalog.
And one of the things that
I'm particularly excited about
is that we now have a premium
section, which is highlighting
only paid games.
And we launched that in Q4, and
we're refreshing it regularly.
And this is also really good,
because, as you all know,
we actually have strikethrough
sale pricing now.
So it's a good way for users
to go and find this content
that they really want.
And we see a lot of engagement
with visitors going deeper
into the page, looking
at premium content.
Within our recommendations,
we're also clearly highlighting
the best of the catalog.
And one of the major
focuses of this year
is actually creating new
editorial experiences,
including this rich,
long-form content
that explains to users actually
what we love about the games.
So not only do you
see editors' choice,
but you actually see
a couple of things
about why we actually did that.
And these articles are
now live in 17 countries.
And discovering new
games is really important
not just to developers
but to gamers.
And so similar to the
way we did with premium,
we actually rolled out
a section dedicated
to high-quality new games.
And this is pretty cool.
This is a
preregistration feature.
And this is called
Milestone Rewards, here,
for preregistration--
which is pretty awesome.
So this is a way in which
we're incentivizing people
to actually go and
preregister for games.
And that is really great.
It also should be a destination
for people to find out
about the games they have.
We spend so much time in live
ops trying to drive people back
to content.
That's the way the
game world works now.
And so we've actually started to
highlight major in-game events
and these live
operations to the way
we're doing store featuring.
And they're exploring a lot
of ways to use live ops.
And this has been a pilot
program for several months,
and we're seeing
promising results.
And so hopefully more of you
will get to take part of it.
One of the things
we're also piloting
is these updates to the detailed
pages, which is pretty cool.
So this will actually
change depending on
whether or not the user
actually has the game installed.
So you'll actually see things
that are new and interesting
that are more important.
You already have
the game installed,
and you may not have
run it for a while.
Or, if you are going to
install it, potentially
then you'll see things
that'll actually
be more attractive, like
videos and stuff like that.
So once again, it's trying
to personalize the store,
trying to get people to go
and reengage with content
through the Play Store.
We also fully redesigned
the Play Games app,
which looks really nice.
And this allows users
to really launch
the games they've installed.
And we've added a number of
game reengagement features.
And so in addition to tracking,
leaderboards, and achievements,
users can now see live ops,
related news, and game YouTube
videos.
And we also have a new arcade--
prominently features this
tag browsing experience--
to help people find
their favorite game,
which is pretty cool.
And these updates
are all leading
to a lot of user engagement.
And that's very important
as we continue to invest
in this surface this year.
And we also added this little
thing that maybe you have seen
called Google Play Instant,
which is really, really fun
to play with.
And I highly recommend
trying it out.
And when you click
Try Now, you actually
get the native application.
So if you've played this
with Clash, it's really cool.
It's a great experience.
And you get an
option to install.
So you get a whole
bunch of levels.
A lot of these games give
you a lot of gameplay
and then really, really drive
the ability for people to very,
very quickly jump into games
and install them right away.
So those are all
the promotion things
we're doing-- those that
help people discover
games, those that help
people reengage in content.
We're also doing a lot of
things with testing on Play.
This is something I'm
really excited about.
We have internal test tracks.
So one of the challenges,
obviously, is you upload--
it goes through a process
before it actually goes live.
With internal test
track, with 100 users,
things go live
very, very quickly.
So you can iterate
really, really rapidly.
You don't have to
wait for Google Play
to spend a lot of time
staging things and going
through your content.
Which is great-- makes it
really fast to use play.
And I think this is going
to really help people.
We also have country
targeting per track now,
which is awesome.
So if you haven't used this,
I'm sure that you'll love it.
Because this is
something that people
have been asking us for forever.
So I'm really
excited about that.
And this is something
that's coming soon, I think.
I'm not sure exactly
when it's coming soon,
but this actually allows you to
create prerecorded demo loops
and use them for prelaunch
report, which is pretty slick.
You'll see you'll get crash and
performance metrics, including
frames per second.
And this will
hopefully allow you
to discover issues
even faster and launch
with more confidence.
I talked a bit about ARcore
and what we're doing there.
It's currently compatible with a
lot of devices, which is great,
and more are coming, on the way.
We have a lot of partners
involved with ARcore,
bringing the power of
AR to game developers.
Which is something that I think
is going to be pretty fun.
And one of the
things that's great
is it's actually
coming to China.
So we're actually working to
make ARcore work in China,
actually making sure
that the product is
available through these
app stores in China--
with Huawei,
Xiaomi, and Samsung.
We also have native
SDKs for popular IEs,
whether you're using
Android Studio or Unity or--
I don't really think
of those as being IDEs,
but this is what their
slide said, I swear.
We also have this
thing called Poly.
How many people know about Poly?
This is a product we have
to actually allow people
to build and browse 3D assets.
So you can find
all sorts of stuff
on there, from the landing
model of a space shuttle,
to apparently a mustache
over in the corner.
And what's really
cool about Poly
is that it actually
allows you to build these
in VR, which is pretty slick.
And we also added an API.
So literally, you
can go to Poly,
and your app can
actually pull assets.
Most of these assets are
Creative Commons license
for free.
You can just use
them everywhere.
And it's really a great
way to get started.
If you're prototyping games,
it's an awesome thing to have.
Or if you want to have
user-generated content
and you want to have
a source for that,
this could be pretty fun.
So I'm excited about that.
We also announced
Google Maps Gaming,
which is a pretty big deal.
So I have much
prettier slides here--
hopefully they won't crash--
which goes through a little
bit of the kind of things
you can do.
You can actually game
in the real world.
You can completely
customize this game world
with all sorts of-- fill
parks with trees, turn rivers
into lava flows.
You can customize
textures or swap out
entire features for
prefabs to create
this kind of
world-scale environment
that's true to the look
and feel of your game.
So it really is pretty awesome.
I've been excited that
we're announcing this--
we've launched
this, I should say.
And you can also design
gameplay around real places.
So you can actually drive your
players to popular places,
take them off the beaten path.
And we actually help
you find great places
for your unique gameplay
anywhere in the world.
And, of course, you can
deliver these at global scale
because it's running on
Google's infrastructure.
So that should give you a
little bit of peace of mind.
We've done a lot of stuff with
Firebase for game developers,
too.
You know, probably,
as you see, Firebase
includes all of these things.
I'm not going to talk
about all of them
because I have,
like, five minutes.
But this is our mobile
development platform.
It's a single SDK that combines
tons and tons of stuff.
And they really
work together well.
Probably the feature that's
most useful, other than maybe
Crashlytics, is Google
Analytics for Firebase.
This product has really,
really grown a lot, recently.
I don't know if
you've played with it.
It has fantastic
real-time support now.
It's wonderful, when
you're going and debugging,
to see the analytics, that
analytics data flowing in
really quickly.
And if you're selling
a premium game,
it's really important, of
course, to understand--
or a freemium game--
to really understand,
really important to
understand how people
are engaging with your content.
And you can measure all this
behavior at no cost to you.
We added this Predictions API.
This is something we
released in beta last year.
And this actually
allows you to-- this
builds dynamic user groups based
upon predicted behavior, which
is pretty slick.
So you can actually
then target these groups
using Firebase Cloud
Messaging and a product called
Remote Config.
And out of the box you
can find predictions
for users who are predicted
to soft churn, users
who are predicted to not
churn, spend or not spend--
all that sort of thing.
Which, I think, is
really important.
We also, as I said, allow you
to experiment with these users
with Remote Config.
So in this case, this
is for Mecha Hamster,
which is one of our samples.
But you can see how this works.
Depending on whether
someone is going to churn
or whether someone is
a dedicated player,
we can offer them different
incentives to continue playing.
And you can use it to change
any parameters in your game--
like UI, ad
placement, difficulty,
whatever you can imagine.
And out of the box we actually
have this web-based composer
for notifications.
We also have a Rest API, so you
can integrate Firebase Cloud
Messaging into tools
that you maintain.
And we also have
rewarded ad formats.
Yay!
So that's really great.
Obviously, we have
rewarded playables, which
involves try before you buy.
And we also have rewarded
with multiple options.
So this gives the
ability to watch an ad
and then choose kind of what
reward the user's going to get.
And we know this is important.
We know that ads are
important for developers
to make sure they're monetizing
a lot of these players that
are very dedicated.
We also have this open-bidding
beta that we're doing,
which takes the promise of
monetization to the next level,
allows people to actually--
allows network partners to bid
for inventory simultaneously
and in real time.
So that is pretty cool!
And then the final
thing I wanted
to mention that we talked
about is that we've been really
working on making Google
Cloud work really, really
fast for people that are doing
things like real-time PvP.
And so Dragon Ball Legends
announced that they
are using it for that.
And I thought that
was pretty cool,
so I thought I'd end with that
for my component of the slides
and leave Bill to come
up here and tell us
a little bit about what he
does with partner-developer
relations and what they do.
So hopefully this will
continue to work for him.
So thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]